[Musik]
das bedingungslose grundeinkommen ist
eine idee nach der jeder bürger und jede
bürgerin monatlich den gleichen betrag
an geld bekommt zusätzlich zu dem was
sie mit ihrem job verdienen und das egal
ob jemand gerade weniger oder mehr geld
zur verfügung hat millionäre erhalten
genau das gleiche wie arme oder
arbeitslose die geplante höhe des
betrags und auch das
finanzierungskonzept unterscheiden sich
je nach partei oder institution die das
bedingungslose grundeinkommen fordert
meist drehen sich die vorschläge um rund
1000 euro im monat die der staat an den
bürger auszahlen soll
finanziert werden könnte das zum teil
dadurch dass andere sozialleistungen wie
arbeitslosen- oder kindergeld wegfallen
und durch höhere steuern die idee miete
und grundlegende lebenserhaltungskosten
werden durch das grundeinkommen
abgedeckt so dass auch menschen mit
niedrigen einkommen geld übrig hätten um
am gesellschaftlichen leben teilzunehmen
befürworter glauben es könnte zu mehr
kreativität und schaffens lust führen
denkbar wäre es dann zum beispiel
humanitäre hilfe zu leisten oder eine
familie zu gründen
kritiker befürchten allerdings mit dem
bedingungslosen grundeinkommen könnte
auch die bereitschaft zu arbeiten sinken
außerdem könnten attraktive berufe noch
unbeliebter werden und arbeitgeber
könnten die löhne senken weil ihre
mitarbeiter ja sowieso genügend versorgt
sind
in einigen ländern gab es bereits
experimente mit dem bedingungslosen
grundeinkommen in deutschland wird eine
einführung immer wieder diskutiert was
denkt ihr haltet ihr das grundeinkommen
für eine gute idee
schreibt eure meinung gerne in die
kommentare